let's see who else we can talk to you
let's go to the 301 area code caller
from 301 go ahead
hi David my name is Joe I'm calling from
Bethesda Maryland and I had a question
about Medicare for all okay yeah go
ahead yeah so I know it's you know it's
obviously been talked about in the news
in the past few months and I know you
reviewed the Mercator study when it came
out my question was how does it save
money
pretty much how does medicare-for-all
save money yes okay for who for the
government because as far as I'm aware
the study says that it would add to this
national debt and the deficit and all
that so this is excellent I'm glad
you're asking this so when we think
about any new government program that
program is going to have what we would
call like a hard cost and let's call
that 30 million 30 billion dollars I
don't know it just pick a number 30 30
billion dollars you have a program that
costs thirty billion dollars so the
immediate thing would be if we imagine
like a ledger like it's you know we
start at zero we have something now that
costs 30 billion great we're now
spending 30 billion more dollars to
really figure out what the net cost is
going to be to us the immediate next
question we have to ask is does the
program allow the elimination of any
other spending and one of the key
findings from that study was that while
yes the program itself was going to have
a cost of I don't know it was like three
point two trillion or 2.8 trillion over
how many I don't remember the numbers
exactly but if you find a program where
by spending 30 billion to use our number
from before the government no longer
needs to spend 35 billion on other stuff
that's not part of the proposal
what's your net savings there okay so
you're saying if it's implemented will
save money in like I guess are you are
you saying like in private health care
spending the government already spends a
whole bunch of money on
health care and health insurance and
what that program what what the the
study pointed out was that there is a
huge savings to be had by implementing
Medicare for all and this is of course
aside from the fact that when
individuals no longer need to be
spending money on health insurance
premiums that money gets pumped back
into the economy that generates tax
revenue as well for the government those
are called positive externalities so the
way it works is we're already spending a
ton of this money between us and the
government in total if we can condense
that eliminate bureaucracy make it more
efficient free up more money for people
to have to put back into the economy
you're going to end up with a net
savings as Gerald Friedman from the
University of Massachusetts argues ok
yeah thanks David I just wanted to get
your clarification on that because I was
hearing a lot of different points of
view on it so all right well thank you
so much important issue really
appreciate the call we will take a quick
break if you're holding don't hang up
because we are taking more calls shortly
don't hang up